- Camille Sanschagrin possède
deux poules pondeuses dans
ce poulailler d'été installé
au bout de son terrain, en plein
coeur de l'arrondissement
Rosemont-La Petite-Patrie.
- C'est quoi leur nom encore
une fois?
CAMILLE SANSCHAGRIN,
propriétaire d'un poulailler.
Coquille et Douzaine.
On pourrait dire que leur nom
de famille, c'est "D'oeuf."
Donc, on a Coquille et
Douzaine D'oeuf.
(rires)
- Mais elle doit respecter
des règles sévères. La garde
de poules exige des efforts
quotidiens. La ou le
propiriétaire doit assurer
le bien être de l'animal
en tout temps, et les coqs
sont interdits.
(chant des poules)
La SPCA déplore ne pas avoir
été consulté par la ville,
centre ou par
les arrondissements. L'organisme
qui recoit une trentaine de
poules abandonnées par année,
demande un moratoire sur
l'émission des permis.
SOPHIE GAILLARD, dir. affaires
juridiques SPCA montréal
- Il est temps qu'on ait une
réflexion approfondie qui se
fasse, que la ville développe
une stratégie coordonnée et
consulte les spécialistes
et toutes les parties affectées,
dont la Spca de Montréal.
- La mairesse de Montréal
estime, elle, que
les arrondissements encadrent
bien cette pratique.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de montréal
- Il y a vraiment un suivi
qui est fait par
l'arrondissement. C'est pas,
t'as une poule, OK, ciao bye.
Il y a vraiment
un accompagnement.
- Avoir des poules dans sa cour,
c'est une responsabilité plus
importante que l'on pense, selon
la SPCA. Ces animaux peuvent
vivre une quinzaine d'années
et la productivité au niveau
de la ponte des oeufs diminue
ès l'age d'un an et demi.
Il est donc possible que
certains citoyens décident
de s'en débarrasser.
- Pour la spca de Montréal,
c'est un réel casse-tête
pour gérer ces animaux-là.
Ils requièrent des soins
spécialisés.
- La SPCA constate également
que toutes les villes
américaines et canadiennes
qui ont permis la présence
de poules en ville, et bien,
elles ont toutes vu une
augmentation importante du
nombre de ces oiseaux dans
leurs fourrières et dans
leurs refuges.
Ici Jacques Bissonnet,
Radio-Canada, M